[Musique]
salut à tous à toutes ces squeeze on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle
vidéo commentée sur cave de chipset de
la cote
donc pourquoi comme de ti cette bague
aux doigts parce que je voulais je
voulais j'ai vraiment envie de savoir un
votre avis à vous qui regardez mes
vidéos
si vous vous trouvez que le jeu est bien
s'il est réussi
si voilà vraiment dites moi comment vous
vous trouvez jeu moi personnellement je
vais vous expliquer ce que je pense du
jeu donc tout d'abord je trouve que les
les graphismes décevant que dire d'autre
décevant ils sont vraiment papa super
quoi on nous avait promis
jeuxvideo.com par exemple les critiques
ids et c'était dû à une révolution dans
la matière du fps tout personnellement
je vois vraiment pas ce cas de
révolutionnaire à part une arbalète ans
est vraiment et encore c'est un an bidon
quand même donc voilà je trouvais ça
assez décevant les graphismes peuvent
quoi ensuite au niveau au niveau des
armes les armes sais pas il son serment
comme dans modern warfare 2 ça se
ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
si ce n'est à si ce n'est si ce n'est un
truc un truc que j'ai apprécié c'est la
diversité des camouflages servant sympa
d'avoir plein de camouflage trouve un
personnellement je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais moi j'aime bien le truc
original c'était la carte
d'identification nous en gros il nous
avait montré sa au début dans les
thrillers mais c'est rarement on va
vendre le seul truc qui vient à manquer
c'est ça le seul truc qui est bien c'est
bien ça donc donc ensuite
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres dans cas de
type de la cote
voilà un roman vous voyez à quel point
je me passionne pas vraiment rien à dire
le lance flamme à huy le lan sa mort
encore un gros truc de nouba comme
d'habitude c'est encore pire que nous
tue c'est vraiment relou un petit coup
de flingue dans la tronche et en heure
c'est génial donc donc donc je me rate
est ici pour le commenter commenté ben
la cote parce que c'est vraiment
vraiment relou comme j'ai
personnellement gerra n'ont pas apprécié
quoi à part eckart d'identification et
les camouflages des armes le reste est
décevant graphisme graphisme bof bof
ah oui les maps peu important les maps
donc les maps j'ai trouvé aussi à
saussines naze france sincèrement je
sais pas si c'est pas le elle l'a c'est
pas du tout la même ambiance que dans
modern warfare 2 chez sais pas comment
dire mais c'est pas la même ambiance
quoi donc là j'ai pris la map
équivalente de rust sur modern warfare 2
1 un petit carré où tout le monde tire
tout le monde se tue dans ceux des
grandes adoptif et ça marche
c'est assez marrant quoi donc voilà j'ai
rarement il ne prend la tête je tire
dans le tas et puis au niveau des coudes
ce cop aussi pour le sniper c'est raté
ils ont sorti un patch anti quick scoop
et puis un patch aller si vous voulez on
voit quand même vous donner une chance
de couette copé mais non c'est toujours
assez dur quand même
personnellement ça m'a gavé un donc je
ferai une vidéo commentée sur la
rambarde prochainement au sniper donc
vous verrez comment comment comment
slides donc aussi le couteau la tiens ça
me rappelle la ce qui vient de se passer
là ça me rappelle le problème du couteau
donc c'est pire que dans mon armoire
fois de ses pires c'est à dire que
vraiment c'est c'est n'importe quoi
enquête sur le mec ça marche pas
défoncer les portes c'est vraiment
commando des fois fait son apparition
c'est vraiment incroyable
je vais m'arrêter ici pour black ops et
maintenant je vais vous parler de
quelqu'un qui m'a envoyé un message très
personnel pour me faire partager ses
idées dont on a une notamment que j'ai
vraiment retenu c'est à dire de faire
des montages de faire des montages
démontage
démontage de en fait donc je payais un
peu un démontage de vos échecs dans les
jeux c'est à dire de vraiment des gros
coups de pas de bol les voilà à quoi
elle est vraiment les trucs affreux quoi
qui vous qui vous est arrivé 1 par
exemple un 3/6 à travers un mur up it
marqueur sa fée bat d c'est comme ça
vous m'en voyez tous à l'adresse qui
s'affiche à votre écran ça ça fait
plaisir comme ça dès que j'aurai est
recueillie à ces deux clips ont fermé de
trois minutes ben je la ferai et ja
sortirait sur youtube donc le jour même
donc voilà donc je compte vraiment sur
vous pour m'envoyer plein de file en
fait pas exprès d'en faire non plus
parce qu'après après c'est même plus
marrant quoi faut que ce soit naturel
donc donc aussi surtout toutes les
surtout surtout chez cieux je sais plus
le maintien vous voulez marque rend
commentaires sous plaies sur tout
chez puma ou en gros sur ps3 / xbox 360
et sur pc a personnellement moi jouent
sur pc donc la qualité ben faut que ce
soit quand même assez visibles ne sont
pas obligatoires mais bon c'est mieux
avec
depuis donc voilà donc je m'étais pas de
musique des arts vous m'en voyez ça au
naturel et je m'occuperai de faire le
montage
donc voilà donc je vous remercie aussi
vraiment un jeu met une petite chanson
là pour vous remercier de mes trente
abonnés voilà mes parents ça fait
vraiment plaisir 1,30 abonnés en
en moins de deux ans moins de quatre ou
cinq jours c'est plus et c'est vraiment
cool c'est vraiment cool
je vous remercie beaucoup je veux aussi
faire un petit coucou à super à bologne
qui voulait que je lui fasse une petite
dédicace je te fais un petit coucou un
salut à toi donc je vous remercie ramon
de suivre mes vidéos c'est c'est
vraiment sympa et puis bah voila quoi
donc là c'est presque la fin de la
partie mon score ça doit être la fin de
la partie
bon score je crois que c'est du 24 ou 23
13 ou 14 et ses plus bas vous verrez mai
puis donc bah bah voilà donc je compte
sur vous avant pour envoyer vos gros
fail donc là je vous dis au revoir
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de
double cliquer sur j'aime et je vous
mets la petite chanson à chaque fin de
vidéo un petit extrait dix ou vingt
secondes maximum comme promis à chaque
fin de vidéo etc merci salut à tous